so I have a number written here it's a
two a three and a five and we already
have some experience with numbers like
this we can think about what does it
represent and to think about that we
just have to look at the actual place
values so this rightmost place right
over here this is the ones place so this
five represents five ones or I guess you
could say that's just going to be five
this three this is in the tens place
this is in the tens place so we have
three tens so that's just going to be 30
and the to the two is in the hundreds
place so putting a two there means that
we have two hundreds so this number we
can view as two hundred thirty five or
you could view it as two hundred plus
thirty plus five now what I want to do
in this video is think about place
values to the right of the ones place
and you might say wait wait I always
thought that the ones place was the
place furthest to the right well
everything that we've done so far it has
been but to show that you can go even
further to the right I'm going to put a
little dot I'm going to put a little dot
right over here we call that a decimal
point and that dot means that anything
to the right of this is going to be
place values that are smaller I guess
you could say then the ones place so
right to the left you have the ones
place and the tens place and the
hundreds place and if you were to keep
going you'd go to the thousands place in
the ten thousands place but then if you
go to the right of the decimal point
now you're going to divide by ten so
what am I talking about
well right to the right of the decimal
point you are going to have find a new
color this is going to be the tenths
place this is going to be the tenths
place well what does that mean well if
whatever number I write here that that
tells us how many tenths we're dealing
with so if I were to write the number if
I were to write the number four right
over here now my number is two hundreds
plus 3 tens plus five ones plus four
tenths so I you could view this as 4
times 1/10 or you could write this as
four tenths not tens for ten
or 4/10 is the same thing as as this
right over here so this is a super
important idea in mathematics I can now
use our place values to represent
fractions so this right over here this
point for this is 4/10 so another way to
write this number I could write it this
way I can write it as 200 230 let me do
the 30 in blue 230 235 and 4/10 so I
could write it like this as a mixed
number so this up here would be a
decimal representation 235 point 4 and
this right over here would be a mixed
number representation 235 and 4/10 but
they all represent 200 plus 30 plus 5
plus 4 tens let's look at a few more
examples of this so let's say I were to
write the number let's say I were to
write the number zero zero point seven
and actually let me go one space even
further to the right zero point seven
six so what would this be
if I were to write it as a fraction so
let's just think about the place value
we have our decimal point to the left of
the decimal point is the ones place but
I have a zero there so this is zero ones
now I have seven tenths so this is the
tenths place and then this is going to
be this place to the right of that
that's going to be that's going to be
that's going to we're going to divide by
10 again so this is going to be the
hundredths place so let me write this
now this base right over here is going
to be the hundredths the hundredths
place so this number right over here is
we can rewrite it as 0 let me write it
this way we could rewrite it as 0 1 0 1
s plus 7 tenths plus 7/10 not tens
tenths plus six hundredths plus six
hundredths not hundreds hundreds
or we could write this as 0 plus plus
7/10 write that a little bit neater plus
7 tenths plus 6 hundredths plus 6
hundredths 6 over 100 so you can write
this 7 tenths plus 6 over 6 hundredths
is exactly what this is you could say
this is zero ones seven tenths and six
hundredths now another way we could
write this you might be tempted well
look if we wanted to write it as a
fraction or talk about it as a fraction
I can ignore the zero that's not going
to change the value of this sum but I
could add the 7/10 to the six hundredths
so how can I write 7/10 in terms of
hundredths well 7 over 10 is the same
thing as 70 over a hundred is the seven
tenths is the same thing as 70 over 100
one way to think about it is if I have
10 tie if I multiply the denominator by
10 well I can multiply the numerator by
10 as well and not change the value of
it seven tens the same thing as 70
hundredths and then you could add 600
600 stood at and what will that give you
well that's going to give you seventy
six hundredths seventy six hundredths so
this number up here a lot of people will
call this you they might say 0.76 or
they might call this 76 hundredths 76
hundredths this is the hundredths place
this is the tenths place but each tenth
is worth 10 hundredths and you see that
this is this is you could either view
this as seven tenths or you could view
it as 70 hundredths so this is 76
hundredths and you could keep going to
the right if you go to the right one
more space you would get to the
thousandths place and then the ten
thousands place so you keep dividing by
ten each place you go to the right and
you multiply by ten each place you go to
the left